sénateur quelques secondes brève dans
ces courtes minutes
2 je crois dire d'abord ma ma fierté mon
émotion la confiance de monsieur
président de la république monsieur le
premier ministre font que je mesure ici
à cet instant l'humilité de la tâche qui
est la mienne et je voudrais vous dire
que la connaissance que j'ai de la
justice et une connaissance empirique
hier j'ai dit charnelle les six mois
laissez moi s'il vous plaît à prendre
mon administration se faire j'aurais
naturellement besoin de tous les
parlementaires de la majorité et je ne
suis pas un politique comme de
l'opposition
il est possible voyez vous de faire
évoluer la procédure pénale de a à z ou
de ac mais peu importe de a à z en
quelques mois c'est compliqué mais tout
de même c'est que lors de la commission
d' enquête parlementaire d'outreau
des parlementaires de toutes
sensibilités ont réussi parce que la
justice nous l'avons au coeur ont réussi
à transcender tous les clivages et ont
proposé 80 de modification de notre
procédure pénale
je m'appuierai d'ailleurs sur ce travail
ce que je veux par exemple c'est une
justice de proximité
bien sûr il ya le budget mais il y a
aussi les hommes l'humanité ça ne coûte
rien le doute
non mais les hommes au sens ne me prenez
pas sur ce terrain les hommes au sens
chez les hommes et les femmes les femmes
ou les hommes
sané sané le signe de rien madame pardon
alors je voudrais terminer mon propos
il ya par exemple des choses toutes
simples remettre au coeur de la justice
la présomption d'innocence éviter des
enquêtes préliminaires qui ne sont plus
préliminaire et qui s'éternise sans
aucun contradictoires
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose de très simples voyous et
ça ça n'est pas une question budgétaire
les victimes qui parfois ne sont même
pas reçu par le juge d'instruction ça
c'est très simple à mettre en oeuvre
j'ai d'ailleurs demandé aux procureurs
généraux qu'ils viennent me voir pour
qu'on parle de cela j'ai lu également
qu'un syndicat de magistrats du siège
disait alors déjà on va donner des
ordres
alors si nous ne faisons pas avec les
procureurs généraux nous le ferons avec
vous c'est tout simple de demander à une
victime devenir une justice plus proche
plus humaine je suis allé hier en
détention
mini salle à part de garder ce bon rap
un tout petit peu achevée vous est pris
par le temps vous bénéficiez de aller
c'est parce que c'est la première fois à
les accords des mois le bénéfice de
l'inexpérience en cours